[Música]
Gracias por continuar en la pantalla de
Franz 24 en español y muy Bienvenidos a
directo cop 27 el espacio en el que les
contamos los más relevantes de todo lo
que ha sucedido en la Cumbre climática
de la ONU que se desarrolla en Egipto
los científicos se van décadas alertando
que estamos ante una triple crisis
planetaria la crisis climática la de
contaminación y también la de
biodiversidad y precisamente hoy
miércoles la agenda temática de esta
Cumbre climática de la ONU se centraba
en la biodiversidad conectamos para
ampliar sobre este tema con una de
nuestras enviadas especiales a
charleshake Marina Colorado
Sí y para ello me acompaña Manuel pulgar
Vidal él es el líder Global en clima y
energía de WWF del fondo mundial para la
naturaleza y fue también el presidente
de la Copa 20 que se llevó a cabo en
Perú Muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotros en France 24 estas tres crisis
de las que hablaban mis compañeros en
Bogotá realmente son una sola están
interrelacionadas son interdependientes
Qué papel o Qué relación hay entre
biodiversidad y Cambio Climático hay una
relación múltiple definitivamente el
cambio climático afecta
significativamente la pérdida de
naturaleza hay un conjunto de modelos
que señalan que vamos a perder bosques
los bosques se van a sabanizar además
tenemos un conjunto de eventos
climáticos extremos que definitivamente
siguen afectando naturaleza y si a eso
sumamos la manera intensiva como
ocupamos espacios naturales la situación
es grave y nos produce pandemias como la
del Kobe 19 y hasta el día de hoy
estamos sufriendo pero a su vez sabemos
por el informe del panel
intergubernamental de biodiversidad y
servicios ecosistémicos que uno de los
grandes dinamizadores de pérdida de
naturaleza es justamente el cambio
climático también es la contaminación
por plástico también la ocupación de
espacios naturales por lo tanto la
ciencia no los está diciendo y esa es la
relación negativa pero Hay también una
relación positiva y la relación positiva
Es que la naturaleza ha permitido que se
absorba 54% de los gases de efecto
invernadero que se emitan y mira lo que
hace es restantes que siguen yendo hacia
la atmósfera son los que nos siguen
causando el problema Imagínate que no
tuviéramos esos espacios naturales que
convierten a la naturaleza en un Aliado
central en la lucha contra el cambio
climático y viceversa precisamente
durante esta con 27 ha habido
discusiones acerca de la preocupación
que existe porque no vayamos a poder
mantener el grado y medio el como límite
de temperatura sino que vamos
encaminados a los dos grados
justamente Qué papel tiene la
biodiversidad en para poder mantener ese
límite que se acordó en 2015 en el
acuerdo de París del grado y medio un
rol fundamental muchas veces olvidamos
que el acuerdo de París nos plantea que
la meta de emisiones del trasero de
carbono que es como que la meta
intermedia para no incrementar la
temperatura en más de 1.5 resulta de la
combinación de reducción de emisiones y
remociones y cuando hablamos de
emociones la naturaleza cumple un rol
central porque la naturaleza tiene una
capacidad de capturar el carbono que se
emite en la atmósfera a su vez lo hacen
los océanos a su vez lo hacen los
humedales y las zonas pantanosas por lo
tanto la naturaleza como te decía es un
gran Aliado si no usamos la naturaleza
para ese fin no podríamos
definitivamente lograr el objetivo de
emisiones de traseros de carbono pero
tampoco podríamos lograr el objetivo de
resiliencia porque la resiliencia
implica trabajar en adaptación de manera
tal que teniendo la naturaleza como
Aliado podamos ser resilientes al cambio
climático sabemos que por ejemplo
reforestación en zonas altas para evitar
desbordes para evitar mala calidad del
agua para evitar inundaciones es un
elemento fundamental Entonces no hay
forma de alcanzar el 1.5 si no es con
una Claridad de que la naturaleza juega
un rol reconozcamos eso sí que todavía
hay algunas relaciones difíciles y
contenciosas porque tampoco queremos que
se utiliza la naturaleza como una excusa
para que no se reduzcan emisiones por lo
tanto también empujamos mucho a que
quienes emitan vayan a sus propios
procesos productivos reduzcan emisiones
y utilicen la naturaleza de manera
razonable válida legítima y bien
sustentado en ciencia y en menos de un
mes se desarrolla en Montreal después de
dos años de retraso por la pandemia la
Cumbre de la biodiversidad cop 15
ustedes como algunos de los progenitores
por así llamarlos del acuerdo de París
en 2015 están haciendo un llamado para
que se cree una especie de acuerdo
también para la biodiversidad explícanos
brevemente en qué consiste este acuerdo
que definitivamente Porque cuando uno
piensa lo que hemos logrado en clima que
de hecho es bastante pero no lo
suficiente para cumplir con nuestros
objetivos uno tiene que tener en claro
que el mundo ha sido capaz de ponerse de
acuerdo en una visión global que
queremos alcanzar el 1.5 el emisiones
del trasero de carbono o el mundo
resiliente y nadie duda eso es lo que yo
digo es como que nuestra estrella
principal que nos orienta y a su vez
hemos creado un conjunto de otros
elementos que contribuyen a cumplir ese
objetivo la agenda de actores no Estatal
es la conexión de clima con la economía
las definición de metas basadas en
ciencia entre muchos otros factores
cuando uno da la vuelta y mira al otro
convenio de diversidad biológica no
tenemos ninguno de esos elementos por lo
tanto necesitamos la señal política de
los líderes y los decisores que
finalmente son los estados para que
adopten un buen acuerdo que nos permita
decir esta es la visión estamos
trabajando mucho en este concepto de
naturaleza positiva que lo que busca es
justamente revertir los procesos de
prenaturaleza pero también alguna gente
de actores no estatales conectar más el
proceso de pérdida naturaleza con la
realidad económica perdemos
económicamente cuando perdemos naturales
a por lo tanto hay que impulsar un
acuerdo hermano del acuerdo de París
para la naturaleza y esto se tiene que
lograr en la cop 15 en Montreal sin
ninguna excusa sin ninguna postergación
pues Deseando que esto suceda estaremos
pendiente en francés 24 de si realmente
finalmente hay un acuerdo de París el
semejante o similar en Montreal hasta
aquí directo con 27
Muchísimas gracias Marina curado por
este completísimo reporte y a nuestra
audiencia le decimos Por supuesto que
sigan conectados con franjas 24 para
seguir conociendo todos los detalles
sobre lo que ocurre en la Cumbre del
clima de la ONU que como decíamos se
desarrolla en Egipto Gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]